konichiwa les gâteaux gaza et massa
allait enfin je suis allé au japon j'ai
jamais acheté plein d'articles own the
fuck dans un magasin et je vais les
retrouver
j'avais complètement oublié énorme le
coup donc c'est parti on va tout et ses
premières article quel est ce si c'est
une doc faith qui apparemment te rends
kawaii nani qu'en fait ça ce mort ça se
mordille elle s'adonne au japon je me
méfie attend une tête tête en photo des
feuilles sa marge à temps oui
n'achetez jamais cet article je sais
plus combien heureusement j'ai oublié
les prix auxquels j'ai acheté tous ces
trucs parce que le mec c'est ce truc
vaut clairement plus 2 euros c'est d'
arnaque totale
[ __ ] le mois de ya six mois était
vraiment beaucoup moins matures a sifflé
en forme de couilles ou comment faire
perdre sa crédibilité à ton prof de bs
qui en a déjà pas beaucoup année en fait
c'est pas des couilles mais en fait ces
dessins le gac parfait pour ta prochaine
grande partie non mais c'est génial mais
ils font passer ce truc bonjour l'objet
qui va faire ta soirée avec tes potes
avaient trop cool ce gène a ainsi jeté
ainsi plus en forme de ça les mecs sont
pas du tout dans l'exagération ceni mais
s'il peut même pas il ne siffle même pas
j'ai envie de me flinguer alors quoi les
contenus de gaza enfin trois fois 500
j'ai acheté une culotte 12 euros annoncé
ce que c'est franchement tu combine ça
et le sifflet mec tu étais sur un stade
de pervers à séoul en gros c'est un
masque anti pollution japonais en forme
de cube ça sent pas du tout la culotte
japonaise
c'est pas parce que j'ai un masque en
forme de culotte je suis un pervers
c'est une blague brand right on n'a pas
ça oh non pas ça mec ça c'est le vrai
truc glauque
ça s'appelle tenga men se loupe et vous
avez vraiment pas envie de voir ce que
c'est apparemment une fois qu les
essayer tu fais vraiment cette tête
c'est une loupe pour observer des
spermatozoïdes
est ce que c'est la fin de ma carrière
peut-être je ne vais bien évidemment pas
éjaculer dans cet outil par contre va
mettre un autre truc qui peut être
rigolo à regarder c'est un poil la
racine d'un cheveu ou d'un poêle vous
allez voir c'est très dégueulasse je
suis en train de guérir son emballage ça
va m'énerver au plan attend le mec c'est
hyper clean qui ont regardé sait pas du
tout où il est mais qui rigole pas quoi
vous dire et 48 pour faire une prise de
sang
c'est génial ok la loupe et là
ici tu as le une poche on veut pas
savoir à quoi elle sert une pipette
bien sûr on veut pas non plus à voir à
quoi ça on a deux trucs comme ça il y en
a un qui se colle à l'objectif de ton
téléphone tactile iphone que tu va
observer tonton sperme
bien sûr dans le métro de préférence
bien évidemment ok je vais en place et
du coup le truc qui fait sous mais
techniquement tu mets ton ton [ __ ] de
sperme c'est dégueulasse sur
l'autocollant et eu kolo zokora ça voilà
comme ça ça crée une protection pour pas
imbibé ton sur ton téléphone d'europe
[ __ ] j'en est bon mais qu'on va le
faire car je peux vous en faites pas
façon champion de lait perdent théâtre
avec un poil c'est et les longs poils
noirs dégueulasse qui répugne tout le
monde a ses bons jeux l'est ok le poil
et mis le poil et mis mes empreintes
digitales avec vous voyez ça a juste un
truc transparent avec un poil je suis
vraiment en train de mettre ma main
comme youtube beauté c'est terrible je
n'ai plus qu'à le mettre là hop là ça
tient tout seul attention je vais vous
dire si c'est ouf appareil photo c'est
le moment de prendre à celle filles
c'est mon poêle ceci vient de mon corps
s'est on est en train d'observer mon
poil mais genre de regarde comme il est
beau mais en fait c'est trop bien j'ai
critiqué avant de regarder vous avez vu
j'ai fait mon vieux coup on vieux et ne
sait vraiment de la microscopie ce qu'on
est en train de faire c'est trop cool
est ce que ce terme existe peut-être pas
peut-être qu'en fait c'est un autre
terme et je suis juste pas cultiver du
to make jeu pourrait observer ce poêle
pendant des heures j'ai l'impression
d'être encore dave était au collège je
suis en train de qui fait ma vie [ __ ]
c'est génial en plus c'est trop bien
parce que tu peux partager ça sur les
réseaux sociaux et aux pattes et espoir
18 ça peut intéresser plein de gens
s'est trouvée il faut que j'offre saâne
aux mannes il va devenir fou allez on
arrête les bêtises on jette tout ça
c'est de garder ça quand même pour non
non c'est pas ça revenons à nos articles
un peu moins un peu moins scientifique
c'était génial
alors vrai c'était génial qu'est ce que
c'est que ça pourquoi j'ai acheté ça n'a
aucun sens mais c'est quoi pour faire
quoi en fait c'est sûr j'ai acheté ça
juste parce que c'est un exotic
shorthair comme jumbo bas mais qu on va
lui trouver une place
ah bah non mais bon voilà on est comme
ça on adopte et voilà comment trouver
une utilité un objet en moins d'une
seconde qui se pose c'est que ça c'est
un truc pour s'arracher point donné ça
nous faire du bien
allez on y va attend il ya deux kits
offerts inquiète à pau a mis ko c'est
quoi ça un masque hydratant en forme de
chat c'est génial
allez vas-y mec ça se trouve ce fait une
allergie mais je vais avoir 600 milles
bouton oh [ __ ] les mecs c'est un bide
il a tourné ou quoi ce truc ça pue la
merde c'est un truc de ouf
[Musique]
je suis un chat oh [ __ ] ses couleurs
p6 a suivi il ne sait pas ce qui
l'attend comme ça n'aurait jamais dû
venir valeur ok ok ok maintenant cette
vidéo art prend une tournure
exceptionnelle dégage une labellisation
peut alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici que des
trucs what the fuck c'est ça mais c'est
dégueulasse et un sifflet père de
saint-yrieix oui j'ai eu c'était
excellent ça va ça vient du japon
situations auxquelles gilles massa sur
tes genoux tu m'aimes fait chaud salut
c'est la provence alors jimmy tu vois
cette image ça c'est nous dans moins
d'une minute je sais c'est que tu as un
peu d'eux était un peu garni d'une et 1
c'est un peu de jeu apparemment c'est un
pacte pour 18 personnes mika au cas où
tu as le pif mon gars mais énorme c'est
compliqué mais clair ça c'est compliqué
il ya beaucoup d'étapes il faut les
suivre une par une
allez prendre des chasseurs à se péter
le nez tous ensemble ces partis choqué
ce top 5 tu mets ton nom tu attends un
peu que sa solide la pression ça veut
dire à l'évasion nivat parti légal
vitamine c refroidissement on y va on y
va on y va
hop t'en prends un peu ok les gars mais
je peux mettre ça dans mené le met pas
très propre
vous êtes prêts top j'avais autant
regretter un truc dans la vie ouais donc
quand est ce que je te l'idée c'est
qu'on va parler des poêles à partir d'un
coup voir s'il avait quelque chose en
toi j'ai un bol mélanger beaucoup de
conneries deuxième essai deuxième essai
cas très bizarre comme substance mais
vis d'internet si après ça refroidit
doom été direct dans votre nées du raid
d'un vote n'est pas tant sa moustache
c'est pas une foutue mika faut appuyer
comme ça assez chaud là avec le maire
sont bas rien déjà
1 2 3 go
mais moi j'ai râlé gym et gym et à gien
c'est bon a jugé ignobles attend
patiemment red house tâche a dormi chez
micro ondes pour ça les amis c'est
l'heure du dernier article
à quoi ce type de bien servir et
pourquoi on ramène plein de bouffe comme
cette configuration de produits pour
donner et et sodebo
c'est simple c'est une combinaison on va
se mettre dans cette combinaison
ça ce sont en réalité les bras de
quelqu'un qui est derrière cette
personne voici l'explication de comment
son fils est dedans très clair très
efficace je propose qu'on s'y attaque de
ce pas pour sa plus belle grave quand
j'arrive à tous ouais et c'est toi qui
vas passer tes bras dans les trucs là
ses bras sont en fait sa demi car mes
oreilles tu vois rien me casser le
principe de fait ce [ __ ] de jeu c'est
quoi ça apparu qui avait dit je veux
bien manger s'te plaît merci merci tu me
la prend j'ai un peu de mal on l'aura le
vertueux ouais pas où elle allait non
seulement vas-y attends je la repousse
vers pause jugée probable renvoi mais je
veux bien désolé je me suis sale il doit
ces rouleaux à ton mec tu vas pas me
planter le palais
là j'ai jamais été aussi peu sera
aujourd'hui au livre des brésiliens à
bananes de grève n'ont pu bosser plus
haut merci mec j'aimerais vivre comme ça
jusqu'à la fin de la merde les mecs fait
tout pour toi tu as besoin de bouger
ok mais cas j'aimerais formica par où je
vais me coiffer simple il n'ya pas mika
ici un petit tuto bottai en direct live
là on se frotte les mains tranquillement
on n'hésite pas à bien se frotter voilà
et là on va sur les cheveux zhao [ __ ]
à chaouen chez le rat excuse moi c'est
ok c'est bon c'est là c'est mon visage
on se coiffe tranquillement les veuves
donc fait une coupe un peu comme ça
c'est le mal reste et pas pendant ce
temps là bien sûr apprendre des olives
un souci régulièrement on est bon je
pense que je peux arrêter de me coiffer
et bien voilà jean sur votre site ne
s'était pas l'aimer ciel vous a plu bah
écoute et morale de l'histoire je
n'achèterai plus de trucs japonais en
revanche le truc qui permet de faire la
main cros copie j'ai toujours passé le
bon mot sur son téléphone
c'est très très bon en vrai je trouve
qu'il ya un délire assez cool de pouvoir
apporter demain faire comme si tu avais
un gros microscope et pouvoir
l'enregistrer surtout parce que c'est
collé à la caméra de son téléphone
franchement c'est pas mal je vous dis à
bientôt une prochaine vidéo est faite
moi petite forme est là
[Musique]